[Music]  this holds a clue to a treasure of  utmost importance  i thought about destroying it a million  times  look at this  in order to prevent it  falling into the wrong hands  the daughters of the plume serpent were  here  so we're talking like an honest to god  treasure map  [Music]  yeah  where'd you get that necklace it was my  dad's  he died when i was a baby  what is it  that's the symbol on your necklace i  know  what if i told you everything you know  about your dad is alive  alec leads to an important treasure  and searching for it is dangerous i know  it is  this is cooler than any room on any  episode of cribs i've ever seen ben  franklin glasses oh my god  i want that relic  everything i thought i knew about my dad  my whole family for that matter is  a crazy riddle that can only be solved  by finding this treasure  just no one  [Music]  what's uh what's your clue i would love  to love to help out  [Music]  you